شكرا لك طلال الطباعه شكرا لك طلال الطباع
شريك مؤسس شركه كوين مينا ونعود مشاهدينا
الى هذه الصور المباشره من بالي التي
للاجتماع القمه ما بين الرئيس الصيني
والرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن همم الوفدان
طبعا مشاركه وزيره الماليه جانتيلا ووزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه كذلك بلانكن هذه هي
المره الاولى التي يتلاقى فيها الرئيس
سانك وجها لوجه طبعا مع وصول بايضا او بعد
وصول البادن الى سده الرئاسه كان هناك همم
اجتماع سابق لكن كانت الاجتماعات السابقه
عبر الاتصال المرئي وهذه اول مره يتلقان
بشكل شخصي همم هناك امال كبيره همم يعني
معقوده على ذلك شرنا سابقا الى تحضيرات
صندوق النقد الدولي في الايام الاخيره الى
انه المنافسه الاستراتيجيه بين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والصين لها اثار سلبيه
على الاقتصاد العالمي
طرق التواصل مفتوحه بيننا وبين كل حكومات
لان بلدينا
امامهم فرصه كثيره
والولايات المتحده بامكانهم اداره
اختلافاتهم ومنعه المنافسه من ان تتحول
الى اي شيء قريب من النساء او ايجاد السبل
للعمل
وعلى المسائل العالميه الملاحظه طلبوا
تعاملها المشترك وتعاوننا بان هذا ضروري
من اجل مصلحه بلدينا والمجتمع الدولي
اوكي
وهذا عامل اساسي
لمحور الكاب او اجتماعاتي كاب 27 قناه
المناخ التي تحدثت فيها يوم الجمعه وسناقش
الكثير من هذه التحديات معا على ما اعمل
خلال الساعات القيد الى القادمه العالم
يتوقع من الصين ولايه المتحده لن تلعب
ادوار اساسيه لمعالجه التحديات العالميه
مثل المناخ او تغيرات المناخيه وانعدام
الامن الغذائي
ونعمل معا الولايات المتحده مستعده لفعل
ذلك العمل معكم ان كانت هذه رغبتكم الرئيس
يتطلعون
لحواراتنا المفتوحه
والصريحه واشكركم على هذه الفرصه
مستر ياسر
في المره الاخيره التي يلتقينا فيها كانت
في عام 2017
خلال الاقتصاد العالمي في دابوس قبل خمسه
اعوام من الان
و منذ ذلك رئاسه فقد حفظنا على قنوات
التواصل عبر
الاجتماعات عن بعد والرسائل والمكالمات
ولكن الى احد من هذه امكانها ان تستبدل
المقابلات وجها لوجه والمقابلات الشخصيه